let's talk about gun school safety and
other subjects with counselor to the
president Kellyanne Conway thanks for
joining us let's start with the story of
the day that we led with which was the
security clearance issue for Jared
Kushner downgraded to secret how is that
sitting in this White House and how does
it affect his job well I've not
discussed it directly with Jared or
anyone else
obviously Jared is in charge of or
supports many of the different
initiatives by the president you heard
President Trump himself on Friday in
front of the whole world to see in his
bilateral press conference with the
Australian Prime Minister Brett that he
has great faith in Jared Kushner as his
senior advisor to continue to work on
matters affecting Middle East peace for
example in other pieces of his portfolio
Jared has been involved with NAFTA
renegotiations obviously he's had a
great deal to do with China many of the
foreign trips he's been involved with
not all of them and so I I don't know
the status of other people's security
clearances nor do I want to i find the
entire process to be one that should be
tightly held and one that should be not
within the purview of your colleagues at
the White House I know what my status is
I know my clearances and I expect that
the rest of us will be read into that as
we need to be sure they're talking to
their intelligence officials they say
you know 50 to 75 percent of the
material that goes over the NSCs desk is
top secret he's dealing with Middle East
peace here that's a lot of top secret
stuff well I'll leave that to Jared and
to the NSC and two others to sort out
but I remind you that you expect that
it's for him to get the truth you do you
expect the clearances coming through was
there an indication that it's him I have
no knowledge about that one right now
it's really not for me to comment on I'm
sorry okay well just one more thing the
Washington Post is moving this story
saying officials in at least four
countries have privately discussed ways
they can manipulate Jared Kushner by
taking advantage of his complex business
arrangements financial difficulties and
lack of foreign policy experience how do
you respond to a story like that
I'm glanced at that story now it's
pretty much just breaking I haven't had
a chance to read I haven't had a chance
to discuss it with Jared and others who
would be in the know so I can't really
comment on
stories that are newly posted what I
will say is I think that there are
people out there gunning for folks
inside all of the time and that goes
beyond doing one's job as a reporter as
a journalist you know since the moment
we arrived here folks have been throwing
logs in our path and it really hasn't
deterred this president from carrying
out the agenda on behalf of the American
people he's had tremendous progress and
delivered results again and again
despite really despite unprecedented
negativity thrown his way in the way of
his family and other advisors last thing
on this day in White House palace entry
is there a battle between John Kelly and
different members including Jared
Kushner I've just not seen that and the
general I can't imagine is very focused
on it he has a great deal of respect and
support among the staff in this building
not only Brett because he's brought
structure and discipline and order and a
process that I think benefits the
president and the information in people
flow to the President's desk which is
appropriate the man is the commander in
chief and leader of the free world he
ought to have time to think and
deliberate and get different inputs and
ideas from people at the same time
general Kelley's oriented differently
from many of us he's in his fifth decade
of public service and that really
matters he came from the cabinet he has
a great deal of respect on Capitol Hill
and in the cat among cabinet members and
certainly here among the senior staff
Callahan let's talk substance on the gun
issue and where it's going here is
Senator John Cornyn today on this
if our attitude is I want everything on
my list or nothing we're gonna end up
with nothing let's do what we can
immediately to past fix NYX and build
from there I'm willing to work with them
the president's willing to work for them
on things like bump stocks the mental
health failure so what is realistic what
you know for immigration you have
pillars that you had to have are there
pillars when it comes to gun control and
safety school safety the president has
spoken extensively he's been out there
talking obviously to affected families
and individuals Brett obviously to
public safety officers and then
yesterday to the governor's and I sat in
all three of those sessions and I can
tell you even in his conversations with
members on Capitol Hill he the president
is he supports increasing the age
perhaps just possession of some firearms
he certainly he certainly supports
fixing Nicks and you saw sandwiches the
background truth that's right in the
background checks he's also talked about
mental health he talked about how he
wants to make it more difficult for
people who shouldn't have firearms to
have them but easier for those who
shouldn't she be allowed to to carry
them out of the second moment to do so
when I say easier I mean the law
enforcement to do its job also give our
give resources the tools to the brave
men and women who are in charge charged
with this it's a complex issue and I
think that nerves have been very raw
because we're all so incredibly moved
and saddened and angered but I would get
what has happened in parkland and
elsewhere but this is a president who
like you did on on immigration on
energy policy on taxes he's bringing
both parties in both chambers into the
White House or he's going to them and
he's working the phones and he's talking
to them about what is is possible in the
end Congress will need to act and the
president will sign into law something
as a reasonable common-sense it gets us
closer to keeping keeping our to school
children safe too we all I can't imagine
that that's not a partisan issue at the
same time we've heard really good other
ideas including from the governor's
right left and center yesterday maybe a
single point of entry for some schools
others are arguing for armed guards
others are arguing for as the president
has said arming so they aren't set yet
you have a lot of ideas on the table and
it's kind of still forming let me ask
you he said numerous times that the NRA
is going to come around that they're
with us that don't worry don't be scared
of them to the governor's is the NRA
going to come around because so far
they're not coming around to raising the
the age for buying a weapon of anything
well the NRA has spoken very clearly for
a number of years as to what they
support and don't support they've been
for stronger background checks before
individuals they've talked about making
sure they've talked about try just
enhanced penalties for committing a
crime with it with a firearm illegally
and the president has brought them to
the table as well he said very clearly
yesterday's he met with the general
credit and Republican governors here at
the White House breath that he had had
lunch with members of the NRA the top
brass there to hear when he says they'll
come around I think what the president
is saying that everybody has an interest
here and making sure that our school
children are safe and that no parent
should kiss their child to buy you and
me included and not see them again and
we as a nation have to stand around that
we need to act with not overreact last
thing
March 5th right around the corner that
is the daca deadline the courts have
done what they've done or not done in
the case of the Supreme Court what is
the sense in this White House about what
is necessary to do to deal with that
issue well tack is a great example a
really perfect example of the president
being open to other people's ideas and
saying okay well then I'm not going to
just take care of the 600,000 and we'll
do all 1.8 million and he said that for
the whole world to see in a bicameral
bipartisan meeting here in the Cabinet
Room with the White House one hour Fox
News cover the entire hour as did others
and yet you can't have the Democrats
back on the table they just won't come
back and fix this by the March 5th
deadline this Congress had all of last
year to do it that the president gave
them another six months to do it and
they still haven't acted and you have to
ask yourself why is it do they care
about having a blunt instrument against
this president in his party or do they
care about helping the dreamer so is
there an executive order that's coming
is there something else coming from this
White House because obviously it's not
happening on Capitol Hill it's not gonna
have on Capitol Hill the president I
will I'm sure he's I know he's examining
other avenues and options but remember
one body in this town makes the laws one
executes this the other one interprets
it and that's why we have three separate
with equal branches this presidents
taken action any number of times through
executive order and other executive
actions when he thinks others are slow
to act or when he is in a position to do
that you've seen him do it with health
care for example trying to open up
health care benefits to others when
repealing the patient Obama care failed
on Capitol Hill you see you injured to
get the coal miner benefits back you've
seen him do it for regulatory reform
he's started to take us out of TPP to
take us out of what he considers to be
bad bad deals so he will act if in fact
his authority allows him to but he's
made a commitment very publicly to
resolving this issue the question is
where the Democrats Kellyanne is always
thanks to the breath